you take your sample you put it on a
rotating stage spin it around
an x-ray gun fires x-rays through it and
they're picked up by a detector on the
other side the dense other material
the fewer x-rays get through by looking
at these x-ray projections you can
compute a good estimate of the density
of the sample at each point so this is
the the main part of the building that
houses a set of three x-ray scanners
like medical scanners but higher
resolution and differ only in that the
sample rotates and the x-ray emitter and
detector stay still whereas in a
hospital they would spin around the
patient and stay still there are three
different sizes this is our original one
this will take samples about the size of
a coca-cola can and do very
high-resolution images of them and this
and all the others produce a
three-dimensional image of the sample in
which each voxel value of voxel being a
three-dimensional pixel measures the
density of the material at that point so
air has a much lower density than bone
and so on we have a larger one that
thinks samples around about the size of
a book it's about 20 centimeters in
diameter and they work to the same thing
they produce volumetric descriptions of
automatic images of the sample and over
here we have our larger scanner which is
a custom-built room-sized
device this allows us to take images of
samples that are about a meter long and
about 25 to 30 centimeters in diameter
so this is much much bigger samples and
we just tend to be lower resolution but
the same basic idea the samples that we
use plastic columns filled with soil
with plants growing in them
I meet along sample can be something
like 80 to 90 kilograms and weight so we
don't want people carrying it around and
we particularly are more people dropping
those into our scanner so they put in
automatically and through here you can
see a large fan of arm and the way the
facility works is the samples are
dropped into the circular ring on the
floor there and the arm picks them up
and loads them into the scanner you want
the robot to move when you're using the
facility you need to design an
experiment which is a set of samples
that they're going to be scanned at
particular times and the whole point of
it is that it's fully automatic so we
need to program that ahead so we've had
an interface built which shows a map of
the facility the round circle to the
samples along here is the the path that
the robot moves along okay so here's the
robot arm and here's the the battery
system the robot itself charging it will
go back to base and charge up this is a
standard glass house we grow our plants
in these containers and here they're
laid out neatly in rows because the way
that we transport them is we have a
laser guided vehicle over here on top of
the vehicle is a laser top spins around
there are reflectors placed at
particular points around the glass house
you can see the cylindrical objects
fastened to the walls they're markers
the robot can measure the reflection of
the laser off those markers and know
where it is and so it can navigate
autonomously around and pick up
whichever sample we're interested in
feels faster the interesting door will
open the robot will put the sample in
then on the other side of it a robot arm
will pick it up and put it into that the
scanner we have a collection of wheat
maize we're about to do some barley we
look almost exclusively at food crops in
here
it's basically because of the turning
circle of the the AGV we've we have one
that is normally used in manufacturing
industry to be able to lift the weight
of these they have to be a reasonable
size we've ended up with one that has
quite a large turning circle so that
fires a laser plane out at about ankle
height and if I stand in the way now
there are what will stop rather than run
over me so these things are intended to
be used in places that are occupied by
humans so we we went for this because it
allows us to have people working in here
as well as the robot yeah the layer on
the top spins around it needs to pick up
I think five of the cylinders to be able
to compute where it is it's fairly
standard technology these robots are
sometimes used in hospitals to carry big
baskets of food around or laundry the
bit of this that's non-standard is the
analysis of the images to pull out the
root structures biologists and plant
scientists in particular looking at
producing varieties of plants that will
grow in the conditions that we are
currently facing so water has moved
around some areas are much better than
they used to be so much drier it's
getting hard to produce plants that will
live in those conditions and produce
enough food the biologists understand
the genetic structure at the plants
fairly well but to be able to produce
the food supply they need to relate the
genetic structure of the plants to the
physicalness for the phenotype but
growers are beginners for centuries of
them though just deciding what one sees
in what conditions and how to they have
but there are two differences now one is
that we need to find finer and finer
differences between plants to be able to
make a decision it used to be that you
could look at a plant and say this one's
so high this one's this high we'll take
the big one
and now it needs more detailed data and
the other one is that attentions focus
very much on the top half as a plant on
little shoots and the leaves and so on
what hasn't been done is manipulating
the roots of the plants because it's
very hard to do in comparison to
biologists have a lot of tools that can
tell them about the genetic structure of
plant roots
but they need ways of looking at the
physical structure of plant rooms and to
do that they have a couple of options
one is they can grow the plants in
artificial medium and clear gels or
water so they can see them take images
and find out what the structure is
alternatively they can grow them in soil
and then dig them up and look at them
afterwards but to keep digging them up
is destructive you can only do it at one
time point and you lose a
three-dimensional structure of the root
when you do it so what we're doing here
is we're using x-ray micro computer
tomography to take images of plant roots
growing in soil and we're developing
image analysis computer vision methods
that will allow us to analyze those
images and to pull out quantitative
descriptions that the biologists can
then relate to genetic studies and
measurements of the plant environment to
try and understand what's going on so we
have a 30 megabyte three dimensional
array of these density values that we
have to analyze to pull out the plant
roots to separate them from the soil
that's difficult because the plant roots
are largely made up of organic matter
and water and soil is in large part
organic matter and water so you have one
problem that the set of grey levels that
you get from a plant root can overlap
with the set of grey levels that you get
from surrounding soil there isn't a nice
clear line you can't say if I have a
density of greater than 42 its root and
less than 42 its soil because that's not
the way it works the second problem that
you have is that roots are very
complicated things living in a
complicated environment and if you take
a particular root segment and look along
it you'll see that the density that's
measured varies along the root in a not
very predictable way it could be due to
the material properties of the root
changing as it gets older it could be
due to the water content varying it
could be a larger effect that if there's
a very large stone nearby that can take
some of the x-ray power away and so you
get a slightly different response in
your root but for whatever the cause we
can't assume that all root
same without the automated image
analysis methods you can use x-ray to
look at roots but what you need to do is
segment the root from the soil manually
which involves someone looking at a very
large data set and using their judgment
to decide which parts of it represent
root and which parts of it represents
soil there are a couple of problems with
that one of them is obviously subjective
what I think is a root might not mean
what you think is a root the other
problem is the time taken on an average
scanning can take four to six hours for
a skilled operator to identify the root
system to a reasonable degree of
accuracy it takes about an hour to make
a scan on average so if it's an hour to
scan and six hours to analyze we would
build up a huge backlog of an analyzed
data on average then that four to six
hours manually how long would that take
to do that with the automated system it
does depend on the on the resolution of
the scan and so on but usually half an
hour to an hour so in the slightly
unusual world where it takes an hour to
capture an image this is effectively a
real-time system 499 were very simple
models the 500th was an action figure
showing bobba fett we X rayed an example
of this to find out what the guy had got